[Music]
All over the world, rice is a staple
food of the people.
[Music]
Over the last 20 years, rice production
in Africa has increased by 4%
[Music]
peranom. But consumption has increased
faster. So Africa is forced to import
large quantities of rice.
[Music]
imported rice can be rice that's been
produced 5 years ago. So the time
imported rice is produced and the moment
we eat it in Benin will take at least 5
years. So this rice is old compared to
the local
rice. Therefore my choice is made. I
prefer living rice. Rice is produced in
Benin. We can be sure this rice has all
the qualities we're looking for in rice.
That is all the nutritional values.
[Music]
Even though the rice produced in Africa
often has superior cooking
characteristics to the imported
rice, several practices reduce the
quality. To convince African consumers
to eat local rice, it's imperative to
prevent deterioration in quality.
[Music]
Among the factors affecting rice quality
are varietal
mixture, harvest
date, impurities such as stones and
drying and storage conditions.
[Music]
Here we'll learn how to avoid devaluing
the local rights.
To ensure good quality rice, you must
start right from sewing by avoiding the
use of a mixture of
varieties. The chairman of Central
Bernin's rice farmers union stresses why
this is important.
When one wants to grow rice, they go to
the market or they buy rice from the
neighbor or from any source. So there's
already a mixture of varieties in the
field. When this mixture is mil,
depending on the calibration of the
grader, if this is large, the finest
grains pass through without being
dehusted and the biggest grains will be
broken before coming out of the machine
because you take a mixture to the
miller. You can be sure you'll get a
heterogeneous rice. That's obvious. So
the seed problem must be solved and
producers have to learn that rice is not
like maze where yellow, red, white
grains can all be mixed but rice it
needs to be selected. The rice field
needs to be divided into plots according
to varieties so that it makes milling
easy and effective. This is very
important.
This seed is from a single
variety. It's only from this type of
seed that a homogeneous harvest can be
obtained and therefore there's a
standard product after
milling. The picture on the right shows
a mixture of
varieties. With such seed, we obtain a
harvest that turns out a poor product
after milling.
So, it's very important to avoid mixing
varieties right from
sewing. It's also recommended to
separate the various varieties
immediately after harvest to thresh them
and store them
separately because during milling a
mixture produces a non-standard
product. Apart from high amounts of
unmilled and broken grains, mixtures are
also hard to cook. Because each variety
has its own cooking time. So to satisfy
the consumer, avoid mixing the varieties
at all
stages. Harvesting at the right time
also helps maintain the quality of the
final product.
When we harvest too early, the patty
contains a lot of green grains and
during milling they turn into
flour. In this way, you lose a lot of
rice and therefore a lot of
money. Rice production demands a lot of
work and without care, we cannot obtain
a good
product. The harvest must not be delayed
until the panacles are too dry.
Because during milling, the overdrive
patty will only produce broken grains.
The right harvesting time for rice is
generally 5 weeks after flowering or 5
weeks after the appearance of the
panacle which is a characteristic easily
detectable by
farmers. At this stage also the color in
the grains
change. The green will turn
strawlike, yellow or even gold depending
on the variety. And generally when 80%
of the field has changed color, we can
start
harvesting. To ensure good quality rice,
ensure you harvest at the right
time. During threshing, stones and other
impurities can get in. To avoid this,
prepare a clean threshing floor. It may
be a tarpolin, bags sewn together, a
cemented or compacted
floor. Farmers in Bangladesh even thresh
on a table enclosed by bags sewn
together.
Threshing can be done by several
methods.
Manually or the use of pedal and power
threshers. Regardless of the method
used, threshing must always be done on a
clean
floor. Let's hear about an innovative
example of hand threshing.
Some farmers in the way we valley gather
the panacles and thresh them on a barrel
inside a mosquito net calmly and the
grains will not escape. They stay in the
net. This is an initiative of a farmer
who doesn't have a thresher. So to avoid
the contact with the soil and other
debris, they spread the nets and thresh
them. After threshing, carefully pick
the grains and winnow them on a clean
floor. Winnow the patty several times
and make sure no weed seeds
remain. After cleaning the patty of all
impurities, it's important to dry it on
a clean floor.
We use the tarpolin to dry the patty to
prevent stones from getting
in. Avoid drying on the bare floor or by
the roadside because stones and other
impurities can get
in. Now let's hear from the director of
the Songai Center, an NGO involved in
rice sector development in Africa.
quality rice could be sold twice the
price. So it is very very important for
them to invest themselves in producing
rice of quality making sure the sand is
not there the unripe rice is not there
so that the consumer who is becoming
more and more demanding will like to go.
Now that we've learned how to avoid
mixing varieties, to harvest at the
right time, and to avoid
impurities, let's see what effect the
water content has on the grains during
milling. Grains that are too dry have
cracks and break during
milling. The cracks are so small that
they can't be seen with the naked
eye. This phenomenon is comparable to
clay cracking in the sun.
When the rice is too dry, it breaks.
That's why it's tested every time by
rubbing it in the palms of the hands. In
this way, we avoid drying it too much.
If the sun is too high, dry the rice for
only a few hours in the open air. Turn
over the patty from time to time to dry
it evenly.
And if possible, continue to dry it
afterwards in the shade.
Dry until the grains have an acceptable
moisture content. Let's see how women in
a Benine village test this.
To know that the patty is dry, we take
some and rub it between the palms of our
hands.
We also test it with our teeth.
When it breaks at a dry crack, then the
patty is dry.
And if you think that after proper
drying the quality is guaranteed, no
way. Storage also determines the quality
of the rice because during storage the
patty can become moist
again. When the patty is stored directly
on a cement floor, It absorbs moisture
and then goes moldy. When the patty is
kept in a bag and stored on dry wood,
its conservation is good and it doesn't
go moldy.
As we've just heard from an experienced
trader, you should always store patty on
materials that support and isolate it
from the
ground. Avoid storing bags on rusted
iron.
Also leave a gap between the banks to
allow air to circulate and make pest
control
easier. As we saw, the quality of the
rice improves when we avoid varietal
mixtures and
impurities. We must also harvest at the
right time and ensure good drying and
patty storage.
Handling the patty well before milling
helps to avoid huge losses and ensures
quality. As you may well be aware by
now, good quality rice requires
commitment and a lot of discipline.
It is important for we Africans to
really invest ourselves in quality
production. That culture of success,
culture of quality is very important for
us to push back all the dumping from
outside. If we don't do it, whether it's
African, whether it's from my mother's
kitchen, people are not going to buy it.
So we have to come to the left to be
competitive, we have to develop
competitive advantage and quality is the
most important element in competitive
advantage and it's at our reach. Within
our reach, we can do it.
[Music]
African rice has excellent nutritional
and cooking characteristics. To ensure
that the final product is attractive to
the consumer, its quality must be
guaranteed at all
times. Rice farmers, traders, processes,
and consumers, we all have everything to
gain from protecting the quality of our
rice.
[Music]